bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition du 78 lactu
de ce jeudi 13 mars comme tous les soirs
nous allons faire un point complet sur
votre actualité local tout d'abord cette
information vous l'aviez vu il y a
quelques mois le 1er novembre dernier le
gouvernement a mis en place une trêve
hivernale pour les fournisseurs de gaz
et d'électricité à l'image de celle que
connaît le secteur du logement il
n'avait donc pas le droit de privé
d'énergie les mauvais payeurs jusqu'au
15 mars mais voilà la date approche et
la CGT alerte sur la reprise des
coupures cela fait quelques mois que la
liste des foyer concerné s'accumule cela
voisinerait 600000 selon leurs sources
pour le secrétaire général de la CGT
énergie de banieu la situation est
critique ce qui n'est pas le cas de RDF
qui se veut plus rassurant dans trois
situations sur 4 on trouve des solutions
palliatives à la coupure pour un payer
c'est en général un
accompagnement de la du foyer qui qui en
a besoin un accompagnement c'estd qu'on
peut les mettre en rapport avec le CCS
de la commune on peut les mettre en
rapport avec le Conseil Général qui qui
qui gère le fond de solidarité logement
donc on a mis en en place des
dispositifs avec les fournisseurs
lorsqu'un technicien de RDF va procéder
à la coupure qui est demandée par un
fournisseur il a une outline qui peut
appeler cette outline pour faire pour
signaler une situation de précarité qui
n'avait pas été détectée par les
fournisseurs en amont et donc à ce
moment-là nous ne procédons pas à la
coupure près de rambouer l'hôpital
pédiatrique de bullon accueille des
enfants et adolescents atteints de
pathologie lourde pour de long séjour il
y a un peu moins d'un an une maison
d'éducation thérapeutique a ouvert ses
portes yolen Torz et Patrick Jacques de
dixmud y ont rencontré de jeunes
adolescents atteints d'obésité lors d'un
atelier
diététique e et voilà quand je vais
manger je vais penser à
toi arrête hamburger fruit h à l'hôpital
pédiatrique de bullon Mohamed Amine
savoure déjà le menu qu'il a préparé
avec ses camarades un menu qu'ils ont
choisi ensemble et qu'ils ont cuisiner
maison lors d'un séjour de 3 mois
minimum ses enfants obèes reprennent
goût au sport et lors de cet atelier ils
reviennent sur les fondamentaux d'un
repas équilibré on apprend à à savoir
manger les quantités les qu'est-ce qu'on
doit mettre par exemple dans notre repas
comme les féculants les légumes ça nous
apprend qu'on peut se faire plaisir en
mangeant ce qu'on veut qui suffit juste
d'équilibrer quoi et c'est ça que j'aime
bien qu'on a choisi ensemble qu'est-ce
qu'on voulait faire et tout et qu'on
puisse se faire plaisir tout en mangeant
normalement équilibré cet atelier
diététique fait partie des nombreux
soins proposés au sein de la maison
d'éducation thérapeutique une maison
inauguré il y a un peu moins d'un an et
financé en grande partie par le
ministère de la Santé pour les enfants
c'est en quelque sorte une zone
intermédiaire entre l'hôpital et la
maison l'idée c'est effectivement
d'éduquer les parents et l'enfant sur
les soins sur les gestes de manière à ce
que l'on favorise alors soit le retour à
domicile soit des
séjours des permission qui permettent à
l'enfant de se réintégrer de reprendre
un peu une vie dans son milieu social
familial avec ses copains et cetera
l'éducation thérapeutique a la
particularité de s'orienter vraiment sur
le patient dans son environnement
socio-familial et d'intégrer donc toutes
ses composantes et de faire vraiment une
éducation personnalisée à la sortie de
cette maison l'objectif est donc de
rendre l'enfant et ses parents les plus
autonomes possibles dans la gestion de
la maladie pour la plupart des patients
il s'agit de pathologies lourdes telles
que des maladies chroniques des maladies
rares des cancers ou encore des grands
brûlés l'hôpital de bullon accueille
environ 130
enfants ce samedi vous allez pouvoir PIR
vous envoler virtuellement dans les
aires aux commandes d'un avion de
tourisme ou plutôt d'un simulateur lors
des de la première édition des samedi de
la simulation à guillencour dans les
locaux dans volsim et le président dans
volsim est présent ce soir Arnaud
monzano bonsoir à vous vous êtes
accompagné de Jean-Louis Richon
responsable communication VAT France qui
seront aussi évidemment les membres de
Vat France qui seront présents pour
faire du contrôle aérien bonsoir à vous
tout d'abord première question à qui
s'adresse déjà ce type de simulateur
qu'on va va pouvoir découvrir ce samedi
ça s'adresse à tous alors après on peut
catégoriser les gens à qui ça s'adresse
ça va le scope en fait va du pilote
confirmé qui vole en réel et qui a envie
de se dérouiller sur un simulateur avant
de se lancer en vrai jusqu'au novice
curieux un peu passionné qui a envie de
se tester sur l'activité ou de faire une
activité de pilotage juste une fois pour
voir oui justement on pense tout de
suite au novis qui a envie de découvrir
un petit peu mais est-ce que ça peut
être aussi un entraînement pour un
pilote chevroné qui veut peut-être aussi
perfectionner et non seulement se
remettre oui tout à fait vous pouvez
tester des choses que vous oserez pas
forcément tester en réel donc des
conditions météo peut-être un petit peu
dégradé ou ou des petits problèmes
mécaniques qui peuvent venir et donc
générer des procédures d'urgence que
vous avez pas l'occasion de faire en
vrai alors le simulateur que vous
possédez à Guill en cours est assez
unique je crois dans son dans sa presse
technique en tout cas dans son
installation lorsqu'on est installé aux
commandes est-ce que on le on ressent
les mêmes sans
presque que dans les air la la grosse
plusvalue que propose notre simulateur
c'est qu'il bouge c'estàd qu'en fonction
de ce que vous allez imprimer sur les
commande le manche à balai ou les
pédales vous allez sentir la cabine
bouger à gauche à droite monter
descendre et cetera et c'est vrai que ça
ça restitue les sensations quand on
reste dans un domaine de vol normal
évidemment pas quand on s'amuse à faire
de la voltige ou autre mais quand on
vole de manière normale on ressent les
sensations quasi identique à celle queon
sentirait dans un véritable appareil et
est-ce que c'est possible à travers un
simulateur de retr inscrire par exemple
une averse un orage un scénario de vol
précis je sais pas je veux partir à pote
à Pitre est-ce que c'est possible tout
ça absolument on peut vous faire partir
d'où vous voulez principalement en
France métropolitaine ou dans les DomTom
ou même ailleurs dans le monde en
fonction de ce que vous avez envie on
peut vous faire un scénario normal plein
beau temps grand soleil ciel bleu ou
vous faire un scénario catastrophe avec
un orage sui du vent de travers et puis
un moteur qui a des ratés des choses
comme ça c'est vraiment à la carte on en
discute avant de faire le vol si vous
avez des idées on les prend en compte et
si vous n'avez pas d'idée on vous en
suggère et on en discute on peut créer
une panne par exemple sur un avion c'est
peut-être très utile pour un un pilote
chevrener qui voudrait s'essayer voilà
absolument générer un incident technique
qui peut vous obliger soit à vous
dérouter soit à vous poser dans un champ
sans vous prévenir de quand elle arrive
pour vraiment vous prendre au dépourvu
et et générer la situation d'urgence
comme si vous étiez en réel et au bout
de combien de temps peut-on maîtriser un
simulateur en tout cas peut-être être
indépendant
dans l'air virtuel ça dépend donc de ce
que vous l'avez souligné de de ce que
vous entendez par maîtriser mais disons
que pour être suffisamment indépendant
pour y prendre du plaisir et et faire
des choses intéressantes 4 à 5 heur de
vol sur simulateur sont largement
suffisantes je le disais tout à l'heure
au cours de cette journée les
ingrédients aériens si j'ose dire vont
être réunis puisque des contrôleurs de
Vat France seront présents quel est
votre rôle pour donc vous allez opérer
notamment la la Lison radio c'est ça
bien le B de France en fait euh est un
est un groupe qui est une filiale d'un
groupe mondial qui s'appelle vsim et qui
fait du contrôle aérien la simulation de
contrôle aérien sur la région France
c'est-àdire que on ajoute au réalisme du
simulateur le réalisme d'un contrôle
aérien auquel le pilote se réfère et
doit s'exécuter et doit obéir donc nous
avons nous sommes un groupe de d' d'une
100 100 150 personnes qui nous relayons
en fonction des des délais des dates et
cetera et des périodes euh de manière à
assurer le contrôle aérien c'est et les
différents postes du contrôle aérien par
exemple lorsque nous serons samedi
ensemble euh nous avons prévu d'être sur
Toulouse et sur Toulouse nous avons
prévu une position Grou enfin sol pour
les Français une position tour et une
position approche de manière à ce que le
pilote qui décolle euh demande au sol sa
clairance et guidé au sol pour aller
jusqu'à la piste une position tour qui
donnera le l'autorisation de décollage
et qui suivra le pilote jusque 2 3 km
après la piste et une position approche
ou départ qui reprendra le pilote en
charge pour faire une un circuit de un
circuit de piste ou plus important en
fin de compte vous êtes un petit peu le
premier contact du pilote au sol c'est
un peu ça bah on est le si vous voulez
quand on quand on fait de quand on fait
de la simulation aérienne enfin quand on
fait du de l'aviation on s'assie pas
dans son avion et on appie pas sur le
démarreur pour décoller hein il y a un
certain nombre de procédures à suivre
alors il y a des procédures techniques
ça c'est le simulateur de vol et puis il
y a des procédures de de contrôle
c'està-dire que le pilote il est pas
lâché tout seul dans la plaine il suit
un certain nombre de règles hein il suit
les règles du VFR si c'est du vol en
visuel il suit des règles en IFR si
c'est du vol non visuel d'accord donc il
est il est un pilote n'est jamais lâché
dans la plaine tout seul un sauf cas
particulier un pilote est toujours sous
le contrôle d'une d'un contrôle aérien
c'est c'est très bien ce que que vous
dites parce que je vais rebondir
l'actualité brûlante au niveau de
l'aviation et et ce fameux vol de la
compagnie malaisienne qui s'est
volatilisé avec à son bord quand même
239 personnes comment est-ce possible
alors qu'on puisse perdre la trace d'un
avion dans les airs bah écoutez c'est
déjà bon c'est un accident très triste
he d'une part bon
ensuite si vous voulez nous nous sommes
des des amateurs même si on essaie de
faire
le la devise de VS mais de V de France
c'est aussi aussi réel que possible même
si on essaie de faire le plus réel
possible on a quand même des limites à
nos compétences et moi j'avoue que j'ai
pas beaucoup de commentaires à vous
faire là-dessus parce que il y a en plus
il s'est dit tellement de choses depuis
une semaine que j'ai du mal à retrouver
mais est-ce que c'est possible de perdre
un avion dans les aires ou pas cont ah
ben on peut on peut perdre un avion dans
les air s'il explose en volile on peut
perdre un avion dans les air si
volontairement
un unéquipage quelqu'un un membre de
l'équipage ou un ou un Brigant
quelconque coupe les liaisons
radio et cetera et cetera donc il y a
tout tout est possible alors là là c'est
un peu plus ça l'air un peu compliqué
parce que l'avion a été perdu dans une
zone qui est quand même sous couverture
radar d'après ce que j'ai compris ouais
exactement bon mais alors après
après je je m'arrête là parce que
j'avoue je comprends pas très bien non
plus ce qui s'est passé très bien on va
revenir à Guill encs donc si on veut
découvrir déjà le simulateur avant de
passer dans les airs on peut se
retrouver donc on peut vous retrouver ce
samedi à guancour entre 16h et 20h dans
vos locaux pour un vol à peu près d'une
quinzaine de minutes c'est ça il y aura
des petites formules ça dépendra un peu
de l'affluence et de comment on
s'organise mais oui l'idée c'est de
faire essayer au maximum de de personnes
possible très bien merci beaucoup à tous
les deux d'être passés sur cette fite
lactu et puis à samedi pour tester ce
simulateur à samedi avec plaisir à
bientôt après un peu plus d'un an de
travaux là la piscine intercommunale du
Ménil saint-nier de la verrière a
réouvert ses portes il y a quelques
jours à 40 ans les installations de
cette piscine étaient très fatigué il
faut le dire il était nécessaire de la
remettre au normes pour par rapport aux
nouvelles réglementations en vigueur
tout a été refait y compris le bassin
que vous voyez sur ces images coût de la
rénovation un peu moins de 3 million
d'euros c'était très attendu notamment
ce qui a été difficile c'était la
fermeture tous les enfants attendaient
là il y a eu une fermeture d'un an à peu
près donc tout le monde attend les
écoles et les associations aussi et les
enfants d'ailleurs c'est le premier jour
d'ouverture regardez le monde qu'on
a par contre ce que ça va modifier je
pense que les gens vont être plus
attirés par la piscine on a aussi des
qualités en douche en vestia et tout ça
qui font que je pense que les gens
viennent en plus mais on est c'était
déjà une piscine qui était très
fréquentée et à noter que la piscine est
ouverte toute la semaine le samedi toute
la journée et le dimanche matin de
légères augmentations sur les tarifs
seraiit tua prévoir c'est la fin de ce
78 lactu merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve demain même
heure je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur
TVF